welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar cannabis and the
autistic spectrum it is presented by
Patricia Frye MD from Takoma Park
alternative care who is a medical
cannabis specialist and lecturer my name
is Judy O'Rourke and I'll be your
moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
Ruth's laberd's is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box so let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Frey I will now
turn the presentation over to her thank
you for that introduction autistic
spectrum disorder is a lifelong
condition that generally begins in the
first two years and encompasses a wide
range of neuro behavioral conditions
that consist of core symptoms such as
impaired social interactions impaired
communication skills and restrictive
repetitive behaviors commonly occurring
comorbid comorbidities include anxiety
ADHD sleep disturbances gastrointestinal
irregularities as seizures which occur
in about 35 percent of patients with
autism the types and degree to which
these symptoms impede the patient's
ability to function varies are mild to
profound
according to the 2016 US Department of
Health and Human Services National
Center for Health Statistics data brief
which is based on information gathered
in the National Health Information
survey the prevalence of autistic
spectrum disorder is about two point
seven six percent of the u.s. population
they do not see that as a statistically
significant increase when compared to
the 2014 prevalence of two point four
one percent in a spot that this 2016
figure may be higher due to inclusion of
higher functioning forms of autism
formerly before referred to as
Asperger's syndrome the prevalence of
autistic spectrum disorder in males
remains higher with a male-to-female
ratio of three to one the total costs
per year for children with autistic
spectrum disorder in the United States
has been estimated to be between eleven
point five and sixty point nine billion
in 2011 u.s. dollars and this is a
significant economic burden which
represents a variety of direct and
indirect costs from medical care to
special education and to lost parental
productivity and wages while the cause
of autism is still to be determined it
is thought to be multifactorial and may
include environmental exposures genetic
predisposition and spontaneous genetic
mutations but regardless of the
precipitating event there is
dysregulation of several
neurotransmitter systems which include
serotonin oxytocin the gaba glutamate
mediated excitation and inhibition and
then there's a growing body of evidence
implicating neuro inflammation and
normal endocannabinoid signaling as part
of the pathophysiology of autism which
suggests that these systems include to
be viable treatment targets and we'll
talk a little bit more about that later
when we look at the current treatment
practices we have several studies that
have looked at prescribing trends for
symptoms that commonly occur in autism
and the evidence to support these
practices Spencer at all conducted a
2013 retrospective observational study
using medical and pharmacy data linked
to health care enrollment and socio
demographic information from 2001 to
2009 among over 33,000 children with
autism 64% filled prescriptions for at
least one psychotropic medication 35
percent were prescribed psychotropic
medications of two or more classes and
15% were concurrently prescribed
medications up to three or more classes
of pharmaceuticals
the authors concluded that despite
minimal evidence of the effectiveness or
appropriateness of multi-drug treatment
for autism psychotropic medications are
commonly used singly and in combination
for both core and co-occurring
conditions in the median length of
treatment with multiple medications for
these patients was 346 days or just
sonder a year but when we look at it
sorry we look at a study like curry at
all who reviewed the charts of about
2,800 patients in the autism treatment
network of north america registry they
found that 27% were prescribed
psychotropic medications 13% were
prescribed at least one medication while
7.4 percent were on two or more and 4.5%
were on three or more medication
13% of the prescribed medications were
psychostimulants 8% were selective
serotonin reuptake inhibitors and 8%
were antipsychotics a British review
conducted by Mary at all using a primary
care database found that 29% of autistic
spectrum disorder patients were
prescribed psychotropic medication they
went on to break it down by gender and
found that in males nine point seven
percent were prescribed sleep medication
7.9 percent psychostimulants and 7.3
percent antipsychotics in females eleven
percent were prescribed an
anticonvulsant which was also used as a
mood stabilizer nine percent received
antidepressant medication and sleep
medication was prescribed in eight point
five percent of those patients in a
chart review of forty five autistic
patients whose parents are seeking or
investigating possible CBD therapy we
found that 29% of those patients were
prescribed psychotropic medication and
the irritability and aggressive behavior
anxiety ADHD and sleep disturbances were
the primary symptoms for which these
medications were prescribed and the
irritability and aggression were the
primary reasons parents were seeking
alternative therapy that was either
because our cynical zhh were ineffective
or they wanted to discontinue medication
because of adverse effects
and so this slide illustrates the array
of psychotropic medications this group
it's been prescribed and we're either
taking at the time of their visit or had
discontinued because of adverse effects
despite the use of multiple met
medication classes to date only one
treatment for symptoms associated with
autism has been approved by the FDA and
that is the use of either risperidone or
Arabic resolve for treating irritability
and autism and with that the evidence
has shown efficacy over placebo to be
only about 20% furthermore the evidence
is based on treating for only six months
and there are no studies looking at the
efficacy of antipsychotic use over time
therefore almost all of these
medications have been used off-label a
2018 British Association of
psychopharmacology study also reviewed
the treatment of autistic spectrum
disorder looking at treatments for both
core and co-occurring symptoms and they
made evidence based treatment
recommendations they concluded that
based on the evidence they could only
support the use of melatonin or sleep
for antipsychotics for irritability in
psychostimulants for ADHD and that there
was not enough evidence to support the
use of pharmaceuticals for treating any
of the core symptoms of autism those
being social and communication
impairments and repetitive behaviors
so why do we look at cannabis well
before we can look at how cannabis might
be beneficial in the treatment of
symptoms commonly associated with autism
we need to have a basic understanding of
the endocannabinoid system when first
we'll take a look at the
endocannabinoids system and then see how
it has been implicated in the
pathophysiology of autism spectrum
disorder the endocannabinoid system is a
six hundred thousand year old system
that is present in everything from hydra
Zola
to humans although insects seem to have
their own unique signaling system and
there are more endocannabinoid receptors
in the human brain than any other neuro
regulatory system the prime function of
the endocannabinoid system is to create
homeostasis or balance and it regulates
a number of functions including appetite
sleep stress emotions memory pain fat
and glucose metabolism tone and it also
modulates the autoimmune system the
system consists of g-protein coupled
receptors lipophilic leggins
to activate those receptors carrier
proteins to facilitate the transport of
these lipophilic molecules across
aqueous cytoplasm and I will go into
further detail on the carrier proteins
and hydrolyzing enzymes to break down
the ligands once they have activated the
receptors
the most studied receptors are the cb1
and cb2 receptors and as I said these
are g-protein coupled receptors the cb1
receptor being found primarily in the
central nervous system while the cb2
receptor is found mainly in the
periphery and immune cells skin the GI
tract the liver and spleen the orphan
receptor GP r55 vanilla-y receptors and
cytokines interleukin 3 and 10 tumor
necrotic factor and peri axis own
proliferative activated receptor that we
refer to as people are are also
regulated by these independent ligands
so the ligands are or as we call them
endo cannabinoids of those the most
studied are the inand amide and the two
arachidonic glycerol which is also
referred to as 2 AG and they were first
identified by pioneers in the
endocannabinoid research by doctors
Missoula and Gianni and the fatty acid
amide palate al ethanol ethanol amide or
PE a has also been found to activate
this receptor system and plays a role in
inflammation and analgesia vital
cannabinoids are compounds found only in
the cannabis plant and they interact
with the cannabinoid system the two most
studied are CBD and THC terpenes are
compounds that are found in plants that
give them their aromatic and medicinal
properties and they're found throughout
the plant world they are not particular
to cannabis the terpenes do influence
the effect of different cannabis plant
varieties and beta carry Ocalan which is
found in a number of edible plants and
spices such as black pepper cinnamon
basil oregano and
Mary is a terpene that has been found to
actually activate the cannabinoid
receptor hydrolyzing enzymes fatty acid
amide hydrolase and mono s a glycerol
lipase which we refer to a spa and
maggle are the enzymes that break down
the endocannabinoids once they are
utilized so when an action potential
comes through nerve and activates the
presynaptic neuron this causes a release
of neurotransmitters within vesicles in
the presynaptic bouton and they travel
across the synapse to their postsynaptic
receptors causing a depolarization of
the postsynaptic membrane and the
accumulation of calcium ion in the
cytoplasm and this cartoon illustrates
how these neurotransmitters and calcium
ions accumulate there by stimulating the
production of endocannabinoids and then
divided into AG and so these
cannabinoids are made on demand and not
stored in vesicles as our
neurotransmitters and they shouldn't be
confused with trap neurotransmitters
they are actually neuromodulators they
travel across retrograde they go back to
the presynaptic bouton where they can
activate the cannabinoid receptor and by
activating that receptor it shuts down
calcium ion influx and neurotransmitter
release so once the receptor is
activated the endocannabinoids are then
hydrolyzed and and abide by Fah and to
AG by maggle
the endocannabinoid system is also
involved in the inflammatory response at
many levels
endo cannabinoids regulate the immune
response of monocytes macrophages
neutrophils natural killer cells in
Senna fills basophils and mast cells via
CB to activation immune cells are not
only able to be influenced by
endocannabinoids but they are also able
to generate and secrete endocannabinoids
that lead to changes in immune cell
behavior as well as the production of
other inflammatory factors that
subsequently influence tissue
inflammation the cannabis plant belongs
to the cannabis family and there are
three recognized species sativa indica
and ruderalis him is a lay term to
describe a cannabis plant that has less
than 0.3 percent THC and these tend to
be more fibrous than the plants that are
grown for more THC which are also
referred to as drug types him is the
source of many of the CBD oils that are
available
marijuana is a Mexican slang word
thought to be derived from the Aztec
word for bad tobacco and the word was
used during the campaign in the 1930s to
column to make cannabis illegal and it
is typically used to denote a drug type
plant that has grown for its THC content
when we look at the biological effects
of CVD and THD you can see that both
have anti-inflammatory neuroprotective
in antioxidant activity and while CVD is
anxiety antipsychotic and anticonvulsant
anticonvulsant at most levels THC also
has these benefits but only at very low
doses the CBD CBD tends to be sedating
it higher doses and energizing at lower
doses and THC increases stage 3
slow-wave sleep which is a particularly
restorative stage of sleep looking at
the evidence for neuro inflammation as a
contributing factor in the
pathophysiology of the autism spectrum
disorder lukina and all reported chronic
peripheral and central alterations in
the inflammatory response in the
Bailiwick acid induced autism mouse
model a 2005 study by Vargas that all
examined immune mediated mechanisms
involved in the pathogenesis of autism
they tested fresh frozen brain tissue
from seven deceased patients as rudl
spinal fluid from six living autistic
patients and found an increase in
circulating inflammatory mediators as
well as an active neuro inflammatory
process in the cerebral cortex white
matter and notably in the cerebellum of
those deceased patients in a milestone
2011 paper pro-inflammatory cytokines
were found to be elevated in the plasma
of 97 medication free and healthy
children between the ages of 2 and 5 who
were diagnosed with autistic spectrum
disorder and these cytokine levels were
compared with age-matched
typically-developing controlled Rijn
children with other developmental
disabilities and increased cytokine
levels of interleukin 1 B 6 8 12 p40
among others were associated with
impairments in social behavior and
symptoms consistent with autism
there are only a few validated animal
models that display autistic like
behavior and when is that bell chromic
acid induced autism that we've described
about previously the other is a fmr1
knockout mouse that presents as fragile
X which is a syndrome commonly
associated with autism and in these two
studies both incur and Maccarone they
found out normal to AG metabolism due to
increased hydrolyzing enzyme activity
in another valproic acid induced
autistic mouse model it was found that
the orphan receptor GP are 55 and a P
part gene expression was down regulated
and that they found abnormalities and
social mobility and in those deception
tests in these animals they also found
increased levels of an and Abidin and p
EA and the hippocampus this is the 2018
study looking at molecular cellular and
behavioral effects of pharmacological
treatments in the valproic acid induced
autistic-like animal models and this was
done by impairing anandamayi degradation
using foie inhibitors you are beef by
nine seven and pf3 eight four five so by
inhibiting these Fah in the enzymes they
were able to raise an anti-violence and
found improvement in these rodents in
social play sociability repetitive
behavior and in anxiety
an independent clinical study of three
to nine year old while of children
demonstrated that CB 2 is highly
expressed in peripheral blood
mononuclear cells of three to nine year
olds and there is also increased
circulating pro-inflammatory cytokines
additionally it was this mark worth
noting in this study that they found
that plasma levels of polyunsaturated
fatty acids which are components of the
endocannabinoid system were lower in
patients with autism
the ventral striatum found in the
subcortical basal ganglia is not only a
critical component of motor and reward
systems but it interacts with social
behavior receives glutamatergic and
dopaminergic inputs from various sources
it serves as a primary input to the rest
of the basal ganglia the striatum in
particular is activated by rewards and
social situations has been found that
variations in the human cannabinoid
receptor see in our one gene modulate
striatal responses and a common single
nucleotide polymorphisms in that
particular gene are associated with
altered responses to happy neutral and
angry faces and mice
and this is a preliminary study out of
Stanford and these findings are the
first empirical human data to translate
preclinical rodent bindings confirming a
link between plasma and amide
concentrations and children with autism
and although preliminaries this data
suggests that impaired and and abide
signaling may be involved in the
pathophysiology of ASD the graph on the
on the Left indicates that the lower the
serum anatomy level the higher the
probability that that patient has a
diagnosis of autistic spectrum disorder
and then on the right it merely shows
the difference in anandamayi levels
within patients with autism versus
patients who are not diagnosed with
autism and the blue is with the
indicator and nanda mine levels for the
autistic patients in this 2019 studied
by Iran and all they measured in an
divided levels and 93 patients with
autistic spectrum disorder and 93
controls matched for age and gender
they also found significantly lower
levels of an and amide but also to a G
and P EA in autistic patients a
potential role of the endocannabinoid
system in autistic spectrum disorder can
also be mediated through its influence
on the anxiety related component of the
disease and the second most commonly
occurring : it comorbidity and autism
relevant to this current review is
epilepsy which occurs at about 35% of
patients and we found we know that
cannabidiol is a it's a fairly good
anxiety and use
these patients it often does reduce
anxiety levels as well as in patients
were not diagnosed with autistic
spectrum disorder and CED cannabidiol
has received recent FDA approval for the
treatment of seizures in Dravet and
olynyk's gaston syndromes this is
Israeli feasibility study looked at 60
children with autistic spectrum disorder
and severe behavioral issues the
efficacy of CBD oil was assessed using
the caregiver global impression of
change scale or the CGI see they found
it 61 percent of these patients showed
much or very much improvement in
behavioural outbreaks and that adverse
effects were minimal thus supporting a
CVD based cannabis clinical trial
here we have another observational study
of 53 patients with autistic spectrum
disorder treated with CBD and in this
study parents and caregivers reported
that self injurious behavior and rage
attacks improved in sixty seven point
six percent of the patients and worsened
in eight point eight percent
hyperactivity improved in sixty eight
point four percent however no change was
observed in twenty eight point nine
percent and it was worse in two point
six percent
sleep disturbances improved in seventy
one point four percent of these patients
and worsened in four point seven percent
and anxiety improved in forty seven
point one percent and was worse in
twenty three point five percent and the
reported adverse effects for limited to
Samuel ins and change in appetite
so in conclusion autistic spectrum
disorder is a multifocal condition that
has significant impact negative impacts
and a large segment of the population
and that today there's really very
little effective treatment for either
court for core symptoms and/or for
comorbid symptoms and that addressing
this abnormal endocannabinoids
signaling and neuro inflammation may
indeed lead to more effective treatment
and I've listed resources and I thank
you for your attention thank you dr.
Frey for that informative presentation I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that this webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
June 28 2019 and as a final reminder our
speaker will follow up with any
questions you've submitted
email that's all for now thank you for
joining us and we will see you next time
goodbye